so I know that it's popular with much of
the Trump astride and even actually with
some people on the left to pretend that
there was never any Russia story to do
revisionist history but of course
sensible people know that that's not the
case there was a Russia story it just
never was nor did we expect it to be
video evidence of Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin personally colluding and
planning things or whatever the case may
be but we've seen Trump do everything
from notify Russia in advance that
they'd be bombing a runway in Syria
leading to that runway being cleared and
then bombed and then of course
reoperation 'el within a few hours to
Donald Trump pulling troops from Syria
exactly in line with what it is that
Russia would want - everything in
between in those two years between those
two events we don't have to revisit
everything today but now we have once
again just another little incident
another data point in the Russia story
because we have now learned and it is
being really confirmed by Donald Trump
that Donald Trump notified Russians
before our own congressional leaders
that he planned to go after Isis leader
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi over the weekend
this was a huge news weekend and we're
gonna have so many different things to
talk about but one of the things that
happened is that al Baghdady
killed himself was killed killed himself
you know this right I guess it depends
technically how you want to describe it
or what you think is most important
about the narrative al Baghdady
is or was an Isis leader the military
went after him in a raid clearly meant
to tamp down some of the very much
deserved criticism of Donald Trump for
the potential resurgence of Isis as a
result of Donald Trump's decision to
completely haphazardly encounter to all
military advise pull American troops
from northern Syria a couple of weeks
ago the details are that al-baghdadi
died after igniting a suicide vest that
he was wearing killing not only himself
but three of his children I mean that
the sick nature of all of this is truly
stunning now there were lots of
theatrics in
volved not only in Donald Trump's speech
about what took place but also in Donald
Trump's supposed situation room photo
while the operation was taking place but
I'm gonna get to that a little bit later
it deserves analysis on its own so if we
remove ourselves completely from the
history with Russia that Trump has and
just pretend this is a normal president
typically presidents will inform our own
congressional leaders regardless of
whether they're Democrats and leaders or
Republicans or vice versa or the same
party whatever the case may be when
there is a high-level military operation
for example when President Obama went
after Osama bin Laden Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi but would have been
whoever was speaker at the time it was a
Boehner at the time or at Paul Ryan now
I don't remember congressional leaders
were notified in advance that this was
going to be going on
we now heard in this case from Speaker
of the House Nancy Pelosi that the
Russians were notified in advance of the
attack but congressional leadership like
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi was
not Donald Trump allegedly told to
Republicans Richard Burr and of course
Lindsey Graham loonie Lindsay about the
planned attack Donald Trump confirms
that he didn't tell Nancy Pelosi he's
saying quote no I didn't I didn't do
that I wanted to make sure this kept
secret I don't want to have men lost and
women I don't want to have people lost
now there is a lot to unpack just in
that statement I don't want to dig too
far into it but you know Trump implying
that if you were to tell Nancy Pelosi
all of a sudden it would leak I don't
know of any history of Nancy Pelosi
leaking plans for sensitive military
engagement or anything like that it's
absolutely disgusting to insult the
Speaker of the House in this way absent
any evidence but let's not dwell on that
because there's much more to discuss
once again all roads lead to Russia and
Putin and Trump admits this Trump
bragged about it Trump said we spoke to
the Russians we told them we are coming
in and they said thank you for telling
us we were going to notify congressional
leaders last night
but we decided not to do that okay this
is not hypothetical this is not
speculative this is Trump saying I told
Richard burr and Lindsey Graham I told
the Russians I decided not to tell
congressional leadership so to go back
to Donald Trump's idea once again that
Nancy Pelosi might somehow compromise
the mission for some reason that he
can't defend with facts when Barack
Obama went after Osama bin Laden he
didn't tell Pakistan because telling
them might have compromised the
operation and after the faculty on
Panetta who was the defense secretary at
the time explained why that was done for
operational security you keep it you
keep knowledge within US borders if not
physically you know I put metaphorical
borders who knows what is in the works
needs to be kept compartmentalised but
leadership needs to know right but Trump
continues in this completely ridiculous
way acting like everything is being done
either for the approval of or even worse
at the direction of Vladimir Putin and
it's not conspiratorial I mean listen we
know the Russian military is on the
ground in Syria knowing in advance that
the United States is going to be doing
this allows them to know here's an
opportunity to potentially observe
elements of the operation or movements
or signals intelligence that we now
knowing that this operation is taking
place we can start building our
understanding the Russians can of the
methods and systems that are used by the
United States it's just a national
security threat that's all that it is
and Donald Trump you know sadly due to
scandal fatigue Donald Trump probably
will not get the attention he deserves
over this negative attention that is but
it's the continuing trend of putting our
troops and our systems and our
intelligence operatives at risk and it
appears that much of this has been
theater stage to make Donald Trump look
good and the way that Donald Trump
listen after this took place Donald
Trump's absolutely deluded you know no
Cystic I don't even know what words to
apply to its speech about what took
place
wanting to be Obama right for all the
disdain Trump has Obama that was a
speech he gave I'm not gonna play any of
it for you where he wants to be like
Obama making absurd claims like he's the
one who recognized the danger of Osama
bin Laden before anybody else because he
mentioned them in a list of like 50
things that are not good in the 90s or
something like that saying that getting
al Baghdady
is bigger than getting Osama bin Laden I
mean it's like we can argue about each
of these things on the merits but that's
not even the point the point is this is
diarrhea of the mouth from someone who
just can't help themselves
in making everything about themselves
and how they look and that's exactly
what we're going to talk about next with
regard to this absolutely ridiculous
situation-room photo